[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in mike florio here
joins us on the program let me uh let me
start with that who's in better shape
mike
jets or giants i like your point about
the giants being in the nfc east you
don't have to be in very good shape to
be in good shape in that division but
i'm intrigued by what the jets can do
dan after hearing
our guy chris sims last week praise zach
wilson the byu quarterback
the presumptive number two pick if the
jets do indeed take him and move on from
sam darnold
this is a franchise that's been looking
for a franchise quarterback since joe
namath for crying out loud
if they get this opportunity and they
seize this opportunity and wilson
becomes
what sims sees in him and i think the
jets are in pretty good shape robert
sala highly respected coach
uh the team being built from the inside
out
by joe douglas mike mckagan the former
gm was doing too much building from the
outside in for example
signing le'veon bell when they had no
offensive line what are you thinking
when you do that so
i like what the jets are doing we're
just so conditioned to think the jets
are going to stink
that it's hard to imagine them being any
good we were also talking about what's
going on with seattle with russell
wilson where the newsletter comes out to
the season ticket holders
and the owner signs off on hey let's
mention the new offensive coordinator
the running backs coach
and uh tyler lockett and dk metcalf and
oh by the way we'll just leave out
the nfl man of the year russell wilson
do you think this is by design mike yeah
well
this is the recovering lawyer in me
talking and i practiced for 18 years
before
abandoning it thank god for this but any
lawyer
with any influence over that
organization would say
if there's any chance we're not going to
have this guy we better not
include him in any materials aimed at
getting customers to buy season tickets
because the last thing we need is some
smart ass filing a class action lawsuit
seeking a full refund on all tickets
because you led us to believe that
russell wilson was going to be on the
team
when you knew or should have known that
he wasn't going to be on the team it
could be that simple
but it tells me that it's serious enough
that they thought it would be prudent
and smart and wise
and potentially something that would
save a lot of money
to not mention russell wilson so no one
could say you led us to believe he was
going to be here and then you traded it
okay so this isn't nefarious on their
part this is just being
smart on seattle's part i think being
smart
is not mentioning russell wilson being
nefarious is mentioning all these other
people that's
where it becomes well who are you going
to go out and see mike i mean you got to
come out twist
you got to twist the knife you know you
got to you got to market shane waldron
the new offensive coordinator if you
want to sell tickets guys what are you
thinking
but i think this is a manifestation and
that frustration they've got to be
feeling because he's been twisting the
knife on them this is their chance to
give it a little twist back
jerry jones is getting credit for hey
i know what the salary cap is going to
be so therefore i can spend this money
on dak prescott
and it made me wonder jerry knew about
this do other owners know about this
why is it that jerry's the only one who
gets credit for hey i know what it's
going to be i can spend this money
i haven't heard one other owner get
credit for a signing because
he knows what the salary cap's going to
be is this insider trading mike
i'm glad you mentioned this this is the
stupidest take that i've heard in the
aftermath
of the dak prescott signing that jerry
jones
somehow has inside information that no
one else possesses
that there's going to be an influx of
cash from new tv contracts
we all know that's going to happen
they've been talking for weeks that
these deals are impending
some expect them to be announced this
week this isn't a secret
yeah no crap i almost said the other
word there's going to be more money
available in future years and you're
going to push these cap dollars into
future years
and the cap's going to keep going up
that's a no-brainer that's that
everybody knows that's what's happening
between the tv deals
and gambling the cap is going to keep
going up and up and up this year is a
temporary dip
and next year it's going to start going
up and by the time this dak prescott
deal expires it's going to be a lot
higher than it is now and he's going to
be in great position after four years
to get paid again and to get paid even
more than he's getting paid now
who has a better contract jack prescott
or patrick mahomes
without question it's dak prescott look
dan last year when the patron homes deal
came out
12 years of a commitment and
uh it's not a a two-way commitment it's
a one-way commitment the team can rip it
up whenever they want and move on and
there's a point where it would make
sense for the team to do it if for
whatever reason he's no longer
a special talent we believe that he will
be and
he believes that he will be but i
remember
that the mahomes deal came out before
the window closed
on the dak prescott negotiations last
july 15 on a long-term deal and he went
with the franchise tag instead
and i asked someone in the know if you
take this contract
and you scratch out patrick mahomes and
you put in dak prescott would dak take
it and the answer was
unequivocally no you don't do that deal
that mahomes deal is an outlier it's an
albatross and it was done with one goal
in mind so his agents could say
we negotiated the first half billion
dollar contract in league history it's a
bad deal i mean think about this
over the first four years of dak's deal
he's going to make
more than 50 million more than mahomes
over the first four years
of his deal and when dax deals done
after the 2024 season mahomes is still
signed for seven more years he's
counting
on clark hunt the owner of the team
being willing to tear up that contract
at the appropriate time
that's fine some owners will do it other
owners won't
jerry jones wouldn't so that's the leap
of faith mahomes took so without
question
dax deal is better 66 million signing
bonus record
75 million paid out this year record 95
million fully guaranteed
record and only a four year deal if
you're dak prescott do you ask jerry if
he can give one of those
golf checks where they hand it out it's
that huge
check like for just it says 75 million
dollars
and he hands it to dak i would love that
photo up because you know jerry's you
know
although we haven't heard from jerry i
thought he would take a victory lap here
mike
why not well this because look damn
they screwed this up and this is the
flip side
of the jared goff cautionary tale
because after goff had three seasons in
and people were saying well he's going
to get a new contract there were plenty
of people in the league and in the media
saying
why are the rams going to give this guy
a market value contract at some point
one of these teams has to say we're not
going to do
this we're not just going to make you
the next highest paid player in league
history just because your contract is
due to be renegotiated
and you've you've been on the right side
of pass fail
the rams did it and now they regret it
they're unloading jared goff
plus something you know they're giving
something up in net trade assets to get
get rid of his contract the other side
of it is when you know you have your guy
you got to move quickly to get him
signed and the longer you wait the more
expensive it gets and the cowboys
waited and waited and delayed and
delayed and they kept thinking that dak
prescott was going to wake up one day
and see it their way
take less money accept the fact that
being the cowboys quarterback leads to
all sorts of other earning opportunities
and just say okay we'll we'll accept
whatever you want to pay us and he never
did
and he finally had them in a spot where
they had no choice but to give him this
contract so it's nothing to be proud of
it's their own fault
if they'd done this in 2019 they would
have done it for a hell of a lot less
than what they're paying now is mike
florio pro football talk live
co-host and you can go to his website
profitballtalk.com
all right what's this mean for the next
group of quarterbacks
lamar jackson josh allen baker mayfield
who gets paid
who doesn't well and this is what's
fascinating about the dak deal because
the quarterback market was irrelevant to
his leverage and his contract his
leverage was driven by
the second tag and the likelihood that
next year the cowboys wouldn't have been
able to tag him again
and he would have become a free agent
that's what determined his number but
now that he's getting
four years 160 it becomes relevant to
these other quarterbacks but
you know here's where the challenge is
for the bills with allen
the ravens with jackson and the browns
with mayfield first you got to be sure
it's the guy
is this the guy and i think raven's
bills yes browns
i'd be tempted to give it another year
all due respect to baker mayfield
but once you know it's the guy you got
to move and you got to get it done
and you got to put a number on the table
that he'll take
because if he waits it's only going to
get
more expensive to keep him lamar jackson
is four years away from having the
ravens in the position that prescott had
the cowboys
so now there's an opportunity for the
ravens to get something done
that lamar jackson won't say no to and
this is where it's important to have a
good agent
you need to have a good agent who is
going to fight with you or fight for you
not with you fight for you
against the team but potentially fight
with you
when you want to take that offer and the
agent's saying
no it's not right yet let's not do it
let's not give in and lamar jackson
doesn't have an agent
and my concern is the ravens are going
to make him an offer that blows him away
that isn't nearly as good as it could be
but without an agent
to slow him down he's going to jump on
it and that would be a huge win for the
ravens if that happens dan
there's talk about tom brady
restructuring his deal
what if brady said pay me a million
dollars
like oh he could do that he could do
that but but if you say if he says look
i'm gonna take a million because
what is left for brady another super
bowl that's it
he doesn't care about the all-time
passing numbers and he cares about
how many super bowls i put up and he's
going to get endorsements
but if he said that now you can bring
back shaq barrett
now you know you you franchised uh god
went like you can keep
the band together here because tom wants
to make one more run here
at least why not do something like that
that's exactly what drew brees has done
we just assumed he was doing it as a cap
favor to the saints and that he wasn't
playing still hasn't retired
if brees would somehow play he's gone
from 25
to 1.075 that's the minimum for anyone
with seven or more years of service
that's the least that you can pay
someone
tom brady could do that if he wants to
he could say i know i'm supposed to make
25 million this year
i'm just going to take 1.075 million you
can have the rest
keep the team around me it's more
important me to this point to get to
number eight
not to make 25 million dollars and yeah
he could do that if he wanted to
and that would be something if he would
do that and that would put them in a
great position to keep all the guys that
they're trying to but just imagine
what that would sound like if brady said
look i want to keep the guys together
what that would mean for that team in
that locker room not that they aren't
you know
following as him as the pied piper but
i mean that's pretty that'd be pretty uh
revolutionary
well it's a and it and it's kind of what
he did in new england now there's two
schools the
thought on why he took less in new
england some would say he was being
selfless he wanted to have enough
players around him you want to have
depth when your starters get injured you
don't want to slap some undrafted guy
who's never proven himself
into the starting lineup because of of
injury necessity
you know part of it too was he was
always
in fear of bill belichick waking up one
day and saying
we're paying this guy too much money we
can't afford this we can do
we can do better dollar for dollar with
someone else so there was always
that healthy dose of what if i get cut
because i'm making too much money and
that's one of the reasons why i know for
a fact he kept his money
in check but this would be the ultimate
i'm giving back my earning potential i
mean think of what this guy's worth to
the team
and this is where i struggle with it
because i'm a firm believer
guys should get every penny they can get
while they can get it they're going to
fill that stadium this year
pandemic permitting because of tom brady
you're only taking a million if you
would only take a million dollars when
you're the reason
that a place haven't been able to sell
out in a generation is going to be sold
out so
it's a it's a tough balance and you
don't want to sell a guy's earning
capacity short
but if he really is sufficiently driven
to get to number eight and maybe to
number nine
and maybe to number 10 then one way to
do it is to say i'm going to take the
bare minimum
you brought up drew brees what's going
on here he's
supposed to be on this sunday night
football night in america set with you
coming up next season mike
hi i i told you time and again they only
wake me up for the unimportant meetings
i don't know what's going on with drew
brees and sean payton told us
five weeks ago super bowl week that
he expects an announcement from drew
brees in the next week to a week and a
half and here we are
nothing from drew we had there was that
video of him uh pushing a sled
i mean that's that's not just a guy
who's trying to stay in shape that's a
guy who's getting ready to play football
so
i don't understand it there's no urgency
for him to do it maybe he's just
enjoying the moment i don't get it
but he's already reduced his salary from
25 to 1.075
and if he would show up and say i'm back
what can the saints do were they going
to say no we're going to cut you
so it's fascinating and i'm sure there
are some people within the saints
organization
they're a little bit nervous about how
this is all going to play out you know
what i thought was the tip off that he's
retiring when i saw that video of him
pushing the sled the the uh
the change the jason whitten uh type
change
up up north yes yes yes
uh there was a little more moss on top
of his head there and that that
struck me as the i'm going into tv
hairdo
let me just let me just make a general
observation
and and this is nothing against drew or
brian urlacher
but once it's gone it's a little more
conspicuous when it comes back
like you need to intervene in the
process
at some point before it's obvious
like you're kevin from the office and
you show up at jim and pam's wedding
with hair it's kind of obvious at that
point
dan yeah i know i know that to me was
the chip off mike
when people say what's he gonna do i
said well he's retiring how do you know
that
because he's got new hair well
look you may be on to something
officially though
and i don't have a second source right
now but i'm working on that mike well i
i will say i i mean obviously i wasn't
even sure it was him in the video
obviously there has been something
that's gone on up top it's not just diet
and exercise that causes it to reverse
itself but
whether that's the motivation i have no
information and you don't have to worry
about that
no i don't look at that head of hair you
got it's uh most of it's mine
yeah yeah but you haven't you haven't
colored it right
you know what full transparency dan
we had this conversation years ago it
was starting to go gray
and i thought hey now's the time to do
it you intervene you freeze it in place
where it is and i did that for about a
year or two
and then you see a picture of yourself
with really dark hair
and it looks pathetic because you're
aging but your hair is really dark and
it's like i don't want to be that guy
and i'm not going to name names it's 70
that has a full head of jet black hair
but is otherwise
70. so i stopped and for the most part
you know it depends on the lighting
for the most part it looks uh not as
grey as it really is but yeah i
that was the remember the bob barker
thing like he took a
week off on price is right and he showed
up with full head of white hair and
everybody went nuts
it's like yeah it was ridiculous before
that because nobody believed he had a
full head of brown hair
you just got to embrace it you got to
accept it just be glad you're alive and
be glad that it's there i don't care
what that's my official position
i don't care what color it is as long as
it's there
thank you mike thank you dan that's mike
florian pro football